Hey, want your baby to grow into a brilliant
and successful adult?
Then stop texting,
Parents!
Hey guys, Amy with you today on DNews.
For most of us, smartphones are an extension
of our bodies, connecting us to people around
the world and managing every element of our
lives.
But some studies say they aren’t healthy
for us, and a new study says damage can start
long before we can even use the device.
Translational Psychiatry published results
from University of California Irvine researchers
who found interrupted attention from mothers,
like a caregiver constantly checking her phone,
can lead to emotional damage in babies.
Ok, so upfront it must be said that this study
was done with rodents focussing on maternal
care of young.
But the authors do say the findings may be
applicable to other mammals, namely humans.
The study looked at rhythms and patterns in
maternal care and found that consistency from
a parent has a hugely positive impact on the
developing brain by ensuring the growth of
robust neural networks.
And this is something that can only happen
in infancy.
The brain is the most immature organ at birth.
In newborns, all the wiring between brain
cells is basically in place to support physiological
survival functions like breathing and heart
beat.
But the connections made in the baby’s brain
in the first five years of his or her life
are the ones that lay the foundation for a
well rounded adult, things like emotional
maturity and social behaviour.
Studies show that to raise the best baby they
can, parents need to actively engage with
their baby via physical touch, social interaction,
and speaking directly to their baby maintaining
eye contact.
This creates far more neural connections than
adults need, so as the child grows, the unused
or unneeded connections are pruned away, leaving
the child with the skills they need to thrive.
Unresponsive parents who are on their cell
phones may only be passively engaging with
their baby, and may be inadvertently telling
the baby's brain they don't need those active
responses.
Research suggests that infant brains thrive
best in a safe environment.
In this case, a baby will feel safe when their
caregiver respond immediately to his or her
needs!
If a parent responds immediately to a baby’s
cries for food or attention, the child will
figure out that they're safe and can focus
their attention on exploring the world around
them.
On the other hand, if their basic needs for
food aren’t met, the infant will feel unsafe
and focus on making sure those needs are met,
not with exploring the amazing world!
For full disclosure, the damage to infants
comes from fractured attention, not specifically
from cell phones.
The researchers looked specifically at inattentive
and distracted maternal care, and a major,
modern source of distractions for both mothers
and fathers is undoubtedly cell phones.
So put down your cell phones, parents.
That text can wait.
Your child’s future as a stunning success
can’t.
And besides, you’ll be way happier in a
few years when you can text your friends about
how awesome your kid is.
And if you think answering a quick text isn’t
a distraction, check out this video about
how focussing really hard on something makes
you go deaf.